so in this video we're gonna talk about
benign prostatic hyperplasia okay where
the prostate is enlarging like what's
behind this and what foods you need to
consume to get this under control the
problem with this condition is it's
going to obstruct your urine flow and
the urine is gonna back up into the
kidney and that's going to create a
toxicity they could even back up into
the liver and because you're not able to
get rid of the urine so it concentrates
and there's a lot of problems with that
now this condition is really affected by
hormones there's different types of
hormones that have different effects
certain hormones have an anabolic effect
on your body that means that those
hormones have the ability to make things
grow alright so now let's go down the
list and talk about what hormones are
involved
the first one is insulin insulin is an
anabolic hormone it makes things get
bigger and you want to make sure you
don't have excessive amounts of insulin
so how would you do that
healthy ketosis and especially in a
minute fasting very very very important
number to IDF one what is that this
hormone insulin like growth factor is
similar to insulin but it's also very
similar to growth hormone okay so you
have human growth room in the body that
has all these different effects that's
definitely anabolic but growth hormone
then triggers the liver to make IGF
which is a another type of growth
hormone but I don't want to get into too
much detail in this video about these
hormones all I want you to know is that
this hormone is another hormone that can
make things grow in the body and to keep
this under control
you want to make sure you don't consume
any dairy and make sure you don't
consume excessive amounts of protein so
you don't want to do a high protein diet
we're going to do a moderate protein
diet without dairy if you have a
prostate problem number three
testosterone now testosterone can also
convert to a more powerful form of
testosterone which is DHT now the
studies on this topic are mixed some
studies show that testosterone and E
HG protects against this condition other
studies show that it can actually worsen
the condition so at this point we really
don't know exactly if this will increase
or decrease it but what we do know is
this testosterone is converted to DHT
due a hormone called 5-alpha reductase
and some of the most powerful inhibitors
of this enzyme help improve in a large
prostate and that would be salt palmetto
and a stinging nettle root so these are
two powerful enzymes that can help less
than the amount of DHT produced so one
point about stinging nettle Road if
you're going to do this as a remedy make
sure you do in larger amounts not in
smaller amounts alright let's go to
number four estrogen I really believe
that estrogen is one of the more potent
influences of an enlarged prostate in
addition to insulin so these two here
have a huge influence on whether you
have an enlarged prostate or not and
this hormone right here is a female
hormone but men have a certain amount of
estrogen but they're not supposed to
have too much of it
now your testosterone can also convert
to estrogen in your body through another
enzyme and this could be a problem right
here so the question is how would you
block this enzyme well it just so
happens there are inhibitors of this
enzyme to lessen the amount of estrogen
produced and the best foods to give you
these inhibitors would be the
cruciferous vegetables there's another
compound called dim which is a very
powerful enzyme inhibitor and dim is a
very concentrated cruciferous compound
so the phytonutrients in cruciferous
vegetables whether you're doing in a
concentrated form or the vegetables
themself help to inhibit this enzyme and
help to lessen the amount of estrogen
produced you also want to be careful of
all the other things that can actually
raise estrogen in the body
soy protein isolates in the foods that
you eat or the oils that are GMO like
soy and corn and canola and cottonseed
oil all can actually increase estrogen
in the body and that could be why you
have too much estrogen in the body so
you want to do organic foods wild-caught
fed pasture-raised eggs to make sure
that we limit the amount of estrogen in
the body one additional point I want to
talk about is sometimes when people do a
key tell they don't do it healthily
for example the foods on keto despite
lowering insulin because they're not
hiring carb might contain things that
increase estrogen so just because you're
on keto doesn't always mean you're
reducing this hormone right here so
anyway I just wanted to create this
video to show you the effects that
certain hormones can have on the
prostate gland thanks for watching so if
you want more knowledge on how to create
a healthy body subscribe now and get
daily notifications daily notifications
that sounds weird well I'll just remind
you on a daily basis about that